merci beaucoup madame la ministre
de venir à notre rencontre dans ce lieu
inspirant
je salue monsieur le directeur de
cabinet et vos collaborateurs
c'est avec plaisir que nous vous
accueillons parce que ici chacun connaît
et vous avez fait partie de ces
délégation l'attachement qui est le
nôtre ou collectivité territoriales non
pas comme un hobby ou une passion
enfin elle est sans doute dévorante mais
parce que nous sommes persuadés je suis
sûr que vous l'êtes aussi que quand on
parle des collectivités on parle surtout
des services qui sont rendus par les
collectivités parfois au nom de l'État
pour nous concitoyens et ce sont souvent
desservis des services essentiels et on
sait que les collectivités alors qui
râlent mais parfois il faut râler pour
se faire entendre
voilà en tout cas souvent avec raison et
avec
justice parce qu'on sait aussi combien
dans les tempêtes ces collectivités
leurs élus sont extrêmement présentes et
font preuve de cet esprit positive de
coopération avec l'État alors vous avez
la gentillesse de recevoir le bureau de
la délégation très récemment donc nous
avons fait un premier tour
d'horizon de la politique
gouvernementale et notre notre rencontre
de cet après-midi va nous permettre
d'aller un peu plus loin et d'échanger
alors je parlerai de quelques sujets
alors il y a le marronnier de cette
époque qui est la loi de finances on a
vu l'importance des questions
tout à l'heure mais c'est un vrai sujet
alors la délégation c'est déjà
intéressée au mois de juillet sur
l'effet du coût de l'énergie à la fois
la hausse mais aussi la volatilité
le contenu des renouvellements de
contrats pour lesquels les collectivités
n'ont aucune capacité aujourd'hui à
discuter et à négocier et le surco avait
évalué en année pleine à 11 milliards et
ce chiffre n'a pas été discuté s'il
existe bien tarif régulée c'était
rappelé par mes collègues ce tarif
régulé touche beaucoup de communes et en
même temps des communes qui ne sont pas
les plus consommatrices en énergie parce
que ce ne sont pas toujours celles qui
ont le plus de de service alors autre
sujet
qui nous préoccupe et nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en parler et on a initié un
travail avec Monsieur bichu c'est le 01
artificialisation nette alors chacun ici
vous comme nous
entendez de tous les territoires cette
voix d'inquiétude où les élus enfin moi
je connais pas un élu qui aujourd'hui ne
se défend pas la sobriété foncière
d'ailleurs certains le font déjà depuis
2001 ou 2002 même plus mais que en même
temps
le zéro artificialisation nette a été
transformée en quelque sorte comme un
homme sacré alors qu'il devrait être à
moyen au service du développement
durable comment conjugue-t-on la
réindustrialisation comment
conjugue-t-on la construction alors de
logements sociaux d'abord parce qu'il y
a parfois des pénalités qui accompagnent
le déficit mais chacun sait aujourd'hui
que l'évolution de la société fait que
il faut plus de logements pour une même
population et comment conjugue en
faisant ça des actions très positives en
matière environnementale donc on en dira
peut-être un mot de manière un peu plus
large alors j'ai lu avec attention le
courrier que madame la Première ministre
c'est une instruction qu'elle a adressée
au préfet leur rappelant je crois qu'il
y en a
61 politiques prioritaires j'abuse
peut-être sur le chiffre ah bah voilà
j'ai ça et ça m'a frappé parce que je
n'ai pas vu la 62e
qui est celle on va dire des territoires
je dis 13 aimablement mais mais
fermement parce qu'on est là pour
échanger je suis un peu préoccupé par
à la fois le discours du président qui
auprès des associations je le trouve
plutôt positive et en même temps si je
puis dire le fait que je ne vois pas
paraître dans les politiques
prioritaires la question de
des territoires sur la décentralisation
la déconcentration c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la saison 2 mais en
volume un peu amplifié de 3DS sachant
que vous le savez que le président du
Sénat a lancé ce matin il en a
d'ailleurs informé le président de la
République un groupe de travail
écuménique au sens où il rassemble des
représentants de tous les groupes du
Sénat des différentes commissions sur
appelons ça un peu la décentralisation
moi j'appellerais ça l'efficacité de
l'action publique jusqu'au dernier
kilomètre et comment les 50 propositions
en faveur des libertés locales que le
Sénat avait proposé
comment on continue à aller décliner il
y a sans doute bien d'autres bien
d'autres sujets donc ce groupe de
travail a été instauré ce matin le
président du Sénat envisage un rapport
de conclusion autour d'avril peut-être
avec un rapport intermédiaire en
décembre ou en janvier il comporte deux
volets un volet on va dire autour de la
décentralisation et de la
déconcentration nous venons d'ailleurs
de rendre un rapport la semaine dernière
sur la déconcentration il fourmi d'idée
et d'observation parfois partager par
les préfets et un volet sur la réforme
des finances locales alors ici il y a
des spécialistes on sait que les
finances locales ont été à la fois
réformés en même temps sédimentés parce
qu'on rajoute des choses on vient
corriger ce qui fait qu'à un moment
la cohérence est un exercice difficile
et vous savez l'attachement du Sénat à
l'autonomie fiscale
des collectivités parce que l'autonomie
financière est parfois difficile pour
ceux qui peuvent lever l'impôt mais
l'impôt ne rend rien donc pour nous
c'est un sujet donc
sans doute on parlerons-nous avec vous
nous avons aussi
en la présence ou en la personne de Rémi
pointeau une obsession extrêmement
utile sur la simplification des normes
applicable ou collectivités
territoriales parce que quand on dit que
les collectivités doivent être frugales
non seulement fonciers mais en dépense
je pense qu'il y a aussi un autre regard
à voir c'est celui de la limitation des
dépenses et notamment les dépenses
obligatoires
parfois super fait à toi qui naissent de
l'invasion de normes et lors de notre
rencontre nous avions évoqué notre
disponibilité pour nous prêter à ce que
nous avons appelé un exercice
d'intelligence collective sur le sujet
donc nous nous sommes vraiment Rémi
Pointreau à son occasion de le redire
tout à l'heure nous sommes vraiment
désireux d'avancer là-dessus et prêt à
travailler avec vous en prenant les
choses peut-être d'une manière
thématique en tout cas voilà nous nous
serons très heureux de travailler sur ce
sujet et puis le dernier point dont je
voudrais parler parce que Rémi pointeau
Sonia de la propreté et puis deux
collègues d'autres collègues j'espère
que je voulais personne de la délégation
on a trahi avec la délégation aux
entreprises on a fait un rapport sur les
services des enfin sur la revitalisation
des centres-villes et centre bourgs
parce que nous avons ici un attachement
particulier au contrôle et à
l'évaluation vous le savez la filature
qu'exerce mon collègue Charles gainer
avec Céline Brulin sur la NCT mais aussi
nous étions très désireux de faire une
évaluation de la revitalisation des
centres-villes et centre donc je vous ai
livré beaucoup de messages mes collègues
en ont d'autres madame la mini je vous
renouvelle mes remerciements Nous
disposons je crois jusqu'à 17h55 et
chers collègues il était prévu ensuite
que Bernard delcro nous communique le
rapport qu'il a fait sur la sur les
maisons France services qui est très
bien mais Bernard Delcroix un
empêchement majeur donc
voilà donc nous reporterons ça à une la
chaîne c'est quand si vous le voulez
bien je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre
madame la Présidente chère Françoise
Gatel mesdames et messieurs les membres
de cette belle délégation que je connais
bien pour y avoir ce qui est j'ai dans
un temps pas trop conscient et je sais
le lien est trois que vous avez avec les
collectivités et l'exigence aussi que
vous nourrissez par rapport
à vos programmes aux élus locaux et au
territoire
dès ma prise de fonction si vous
permettez je vais faire une petite
introduction avant de répondre à vos
questions j'ai d'ores et déjà reçu les
toutes les associations d'élus seul ou
avec Christophe Béchu ne je les ai
écoutés j'ai maintenu le dialogue qui
sont d'ailleurs je voudrais vous le dire
le fil conducteur de ma feuille de route
comme cela a toujours été d'ailleurs
dans ma vie des lieux locales je suis en
effet persuadée qu'une politique
publique concertée partagée le plus en
amont possible
est une politique publique efficace
adaptée aux besoins du terrain et aux
attentes des élus et de nos concitoyens
je vais pas davantage insister sur la
méthode je voudrais parce que je sais et
vous l'avez déjà dit vos questions sont
nombreuses je voudrais simplement vous
parler de ma feuille de route à court et
moyen terme en premier lieu l'actualité
qui occupera nos prochaines semaines
c'est évidemment le projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 qui traduit
l'accompagnement de l'État pour aider
les collectivités à faire face à la
situation je sais que vous êtes ici des
experts des finances publiques n'est ce
pas cher
sénateur Charles Guénet le premier qui
d'ailleurs a suivi avec attention à ce
sujet en commission des finances
mais c'est vrai que cela était rappelé
avec précision lors des QAG je voudrais
évidemment revenir quelques instants sur
le fond de 430 millions d'euros pour
aider les communes qui a été votée en
loi de finances rectificative l'été
dernier pour aider les communes et les
intercommunalités les plus fragiles à
faire face à la hausse du point d'indice
à la hausse du cou de l'alimentation et
de l'énergie et sont décret
d'application est d'ailleurs passé
monsieur le directeur des finances
locales ce matin en comité pour 2023 le
gouvernement maintient son soutien aux
collectivités face à l'inflation et au
prix de l'énergie il s'agit de la
prolongation du bouclier tarifaire en
2023 fin de limiter à 15% la hausse des
prix de l'électricité et du gaz pour les
plus petites communes soit environ 28
000 collectivités pour être très
transparente je pense que nous ne
saurons que après le contaministratif de
2023 quel est
l'ampleur disant de ces collectivités
qui pourront en bénéficier alors
bouclier tarifaire mais aussi
quadruplement de l'enveloppe à
destination des communes alors en très
grande difficulté qui atteint 10
millions d'euros
grande difficulté je précise ce sont
évidemment les indicateurs sociaux les
critères de charges et de ressources et
le potentiel financier qui sont
évidemment les conditions d'obtention de
cette enveloppe
par ailleurs j'ai proposé avec
Christophe Béchu à la première ministre
une hausse de 210 millions d'euros de la
DSE et de la DSR qui seront financés par
l'État et non par écritement des autres
communes alors bien sûr le PLF ne le
prévoit pas encore mais un amendement
confirmera le financement de cette
hausse de la péréquation verticale par
des crédits nouveaux
c'est aussi inédite depuis 13 ans je me
permets de la rappeler permettra à 70%
des collectivités de voir leur dotation
augmentée ou stabiliser j'entends les
critiques quant à la non-addexation de
la DGF sur l'inflation je voudrais
simplement vous rappeler que ça ne date
pas ni d'hier mais de 2010
par ailleurs cette augmentation de 210
millions d'euros s'inscrit dans un
contexte contraint pour les finances de
l'État et doit être interprété de mon
point de vue comme une marque de
confiance vis-à-vis des collectivités et
des élus locaux d'autres mesures je les
balayerai rapidement traduisent aussi le
soutien que l'État porte aux élus je
pense à l'augmentation d'un tiers des
moyens consacrés à la dotation
biodiversité pour 2023 qui avait déjà
été doublé en 2022 nous sommes passés à
24 millions d'euros en 22 à 30 dans le
PLF pour 2023 et je sais que certains
d'entre vous y portent une grande
attention n'est-ce pas monsieur le
sénateur Bernard delcro
je souhaite enfin vous préciser que les
élus pourront dorénavant bénéficier d'un
remboursement forfaitisé des frais de
garde au lieu de déposer un dossier de
remboursement des frais réels
l'enveloppe sera augmentée d'un million
d'euros je pense que c'est une mesure
concrète que j'ai souhaité prendre pour
inciter l'engagement local de jeunes
parents et leur permettre d'exercer leur
mandat dans de bonnes conditions ensuite
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
l'état prescripteur que nous avons et je
me mets à votre place souvent dénoncé
collectivement je souhaite vous parler
de l'État accompagnateur je voudrais
vous redire qu'en 2023 l'État sera aux
côtés des élus pour les accompagner à
réaliser leurs projets territoire nous
allons consacrer un effort majeur à la
préparation de l'avenir puisque les
dotations d'investissement atteindront
en 2023 un niveau proche de 2 milliards
d'euros
nous irons d'ailleurs plus loin puisque
je crois que nous ne pourrons surmonter
durablement les difficultés du temps
présent sans accélérer les transitions
énergétiques et écologiques dans les
territoires l'État va donc s'engager
fortement avec la création d'un fond
vert qui mobilisera en effet un milliard
cinq d'euros en 2023 pour développer les
projets de transition écologique
concrètement il pourra s'agir de
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
publics de renaturation en ville ou dans
des cours d'école d'aménagement des
friches ou encore du trait de côte en
termes de méthodes nous souhaitons
privilégier avec Christophe Béchu des
règles simples et décentralisés sans
appel à projet je le redis tout partira
des projets des élus locaux selon une
méthode simple et reconnue celle du
dialogue entre les élus et leur préfet
de département ou de région un appui à
l'ingénierie sera également proposé pour
les communes les moins outillées il
existait déjà par le biais de l'anct
pour les communes de moins de 3500
habitants et gratuitement j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises
l'état accompagnateur c'est également
l'état qui accompagne les territoires
selon une logique différenciée comme
cela se fait grâce au Programme d'appui
porté par la NCT des sujets sur lesquels
plusieurs d'entre vous ont travaillé je
le sais autour de
Rémi Pointreau qui était le rapporteur
et dont je salue le rapport qui a été
présenté la semaine dernière et sur
lequel nous aurons sûrement l'occasion
d'échanger
à cet égard je vous précise que je
réunirai ce vendredi
à mon ministère un comité exécutif du
programme Action de ville 2 réunissant
l'ensemble des partenaires du programme
la banque des territoires actions
logements Lana et bien sûr l'État afin
de procéder autour de table des
accompagnements financiers de la phase 2
qui sera annoncé dans les prochaines
semaines par la première ministre
je peux d'ores et déjà vous dire que
cette seconde phase nous la souhaitons
ambitieuse qu'elle portera évidemment en
priorité sur la transition écologique et
énergétique dans les villes mais aussi
sur la question des entrées de villes et
la question des quartiers de gare cela
répond je crois concrètement à la
demande formulée par les 234 mères
bénéficiaires du plan
je voudrais aussi vous dire que nous
allons consolider le programme petite
ville de demain qui s'adresse à 1600
communes de moins de 20 000 habitants
j'ai à ce titre
missionné les équipes de la NCT pour une
feuille de route plus opérationnelle
pour répondre aux attentes qui me sont
remontées des élus et je ne manquerai
pas de vous en faire part car je connais
pour mes déplacés dans un certain nombre
de départements votre attachement à ce
programme qui accompagne de nombreux
territoires ruraux notamment en
conclusion avant d'ouvrir le débat
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs très
brièvement sur une question qui nous
tient toutes et tous à coeur le
quotidien des élus comme vous et je me
permets de prendre la présence gatelle à
témoin tant et œuvre activement sur la
mise en oeuvre de la loi 3DS et sur ces
suites j'aurai à coeur de travailler
aussi sur ce sujet sujet et vous me
trouverez évidemment aux côtés des élus
pour simplifier leur relation avec
l'État
je souhaite en effet porter des
politiques publiques différenciées dans
l'esprit de la loi 3DS adaptée aux
réalités locales je crois que les outils
existent et qu'il faut que les élus sans
saisissent certains départements
d'ailleurs ont souhaité que leurs
compétences RSA soient partagées avec
l'État et ils sont en train
d'expérimenter justement ce nouveau
dispositif certains ont voulu en prendre
en charge la gestion de route nationale
dans un intérêt local reconnu et je
crois que c'est par ce type d'initiative
que l'action publique gagnera en
efficacité et en cohérence et puis vous
avez également réfléchi à la place de
l'État dans nos territoires je ne l'ai
pas vu mais je voulais remercier la
sénatrice Agnès canaillé pour son
rapport fournissant de nombreuses pistes
de travail
l'efficacité de nos politiques publiques
territorialisées passent bien par un
état déconcentré
consolider en mesure de les accompagner
et de répondre aux élus locaux voilà je
voudrais vous redire que
la confiance du gouvernement dans les
dans les élus locaux et total mais
au-delà de cette confiance je voudrais
rappeler que je me tiens évidemment avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues aux côtés
des élus locaux pour les accompagner
dans leur projet
j'ajouterai aussi pour les défendre et
les soutenir quand ils sont
scandaleusement victimes d'agression et
je suis frappée par le fait que plus
d'une fois par semaine j'ai à prendre
contact avec des mères qui ont été où
attaquer ou dont les permanences ont été
brûlées ou dont les cabinets médicaux
ont été
brûlés également donc sur ce dernier
point sachez en tout cas que de la part
du ministre de l'Intérieur la loi sera
ferme et qu'elle doit être pleinement
appliquée voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire en guise la production de cette
réunion et évidemment je vais répondre
sur les sujets que vous avez peut-être
déjà abordé on peut peut-être démarrer
sur Lausanne si vous voulez bien
alors nous ne sommes pas un grave moi je
note avec plaisir tous les signes
positifs il y a de nombreuses prises de
parole donc je serai brève mais juste
en écho très rapidement il y a des
choses qui n'appellent pas de de réponse
sur la DGF rien d'interdit d'être
disruptif madame la ministre vous avez
dit que depuis 10 ans il y a une règle
qui qui dit que en indexe pas je dirais
juste que la situation est assez
disruptive on a une inflation une hausse
de coude de l'énergie qui vraiment
en ayant comme chacun d'entre nous ici
le sens des responsabilités de la
contrainte de l'État
une une demande de prise en compte de
l'indexation sur l'inflation ça veut
dire qu'elle n'est que conjoncturelle je
sais que ça coûte un milliard comme il y
a c'est beaucoup je rappellerai jusque
la hausse de coût de l'énergie c'est 11
milliards je pense que là on a on a un
écart deuxième point qui s'adresse
peut-être
à Monsieur le Directeur de la DGCL nous
avons alors je veux saluer le changement
de méthode où nous sommes associés à
l'écriture des traits d'application on a
travaillé avec Charles Guénet d'autres
collègues sur le décret d'applications
de la disposition en faveur
des collectivités qui étaient adoptées
dans le PLFR alors je vais être sûr
d'avoir bien compris comme nous avons
travaillé sur le sujet nous avons
demandé à ce que ce ne soit pas les
collectivités qui sollicitent l'aide
sans savoir si elles seront vraiment
éligibles parce qu'elles ne sont qu'en
2023 nous pensons parce que nous avons
une grande confiance dans les services
de l'État qu'il n'y a aucun secret pour
la Dr Philippe et que les Dr FIP seront
plus à même d'informer les collectivités
quels sont éligibles ensuite elles
peuvent faire vous demande d'acompte
donc je voudrais être sûr que c'est bien
ce mécanisme qui se met en place trois
troisième point c'est sur l'action
logement vous avez parlé des programmes
coeur de vie des petites villes de
demain qui sont des très beaux
programmes et je pense qu'il faut
envisager d'élargir l'action logement à
petite ville de demain parce que
beaucoup de programmes petites villes de
demain ne peuvent pas décoller parce
qu'il y a des des difficultés en matière
de financement de logement et puis avant
de passer la parole à mes collègues je
vous remercie
du message que vous passez à l'attention
de nos collègues élus les maires qui
sont vraiment la prison du Sénat elle
habitude de dire qu'il soit portée
d'engueulade mais là ils sont apportés
de coup eux et leurs familles je sais
l'attention que vous portez le ministre
d'intérieur il nous avons eu l'occasion
d'auditionner le garde des sceaux avant
l'été pour suivre
la manière dont les dispositions que
nous avons prises dans une dans une loi
sur le lien procureur mère se mettait en
place donc merci à vous et c'est un
sujet qui devient effectivement
important et très préoccupant monsieur
le pourrait me faire un petit mot à ma
question vous pouvez juste me répondre
par oui j'ai bien compris ce sera bien
je vais passer la parole à notre
collèguemi pintro qui devra nous quitter
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'audition en
ce moment ensuite Didier Rambaud Bernard
buis on peut faire ce premier trio si
vous êtes d'accord ensuite Patricia
Schillinger c'est libre là Laurent
Burgaud vous ait beaucoup de succès
madame la ministre et il y aura
Laurenceau et Bernard delcro et Madame
Sonia de la pauvreté et Madame Estrosi
ça sonne alors cher Rémi puis j'y ai pu
Bernard merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre alors je vais pas
vous parler des petites villes de demain
de la revitalisation des centres-villes
et centre beau parce qu'on en a
beaucoup parlé déjà au sein de la
délégation et puis moi je me réjouis
d'avance de voir que vous allez prendre
en compte nos préconisations je pense
que c'est ça qui est le plus important
je vais pas vous parler non plus de la
simplification des normes puisque nous
allons faire un travail avec notre
présidente Françoise Gatel dans quelques
semaines et nous aurons à travailler
aussi sur la
Commission nationale d'évaluation des
normes qui travaillent avec trop peu de
moyens et il faut qu'on leur donne un
peu qu'on renforce un petit peu la
Commission nationale d'évaluation des
normes pour les notamment des normes des
collectivités moi je voudrais simplement
vous parler d'un sujet
qui inquiète beaucoup les élus c'est la
ce sont les modalités de reversement de
la taxe d'aménagement des communes aux
intercommunalités et l'article 109 de la
loi de finances pour 2022 a rendu
obligatoire le reversement par les
communes de tout ou partie du produit de
la taxe d'aménagement aux
intercommunalités compte tenu soit
disant de la charge des équipements
publics relevant des compétences de ces
dernières c'était jusqu'à présent
facultatif
et malheureusement donc cette mesure qui
a été introduite à l'Assemblée nationale
va réduire la liberté de laisser au
collectivités locales en matière de
répartition du produit de la taxe
puisque avant ça se négocier entre la
commune et les interco et les élus
estiment qu'il y a une rupture du
dialogue avec les intercommunalités
puisque on leur impose un reversement et
ont d'ailleurs en plus on demande que
ces modalités de reversement soient
fixés par délibération
concordantes depuis le 1er octobre pour
une autre vigueur en 2023
donc outre le fait qu'on peut
s'interroger du cas où par exemple une
commune refuse de délibérer sur ce sujet
les délais sont jugés par nos élus étant
extrêmement court
d'autant plus qu'il ne tiennent pas
compte de la périodicité des réunions
parfois trimestrielles qui se passent au
niveau des qui réunissent ces conseils
municipaux dans les communes rurales
donc je voudrais simplement
connaître Madame le Ministre vos
intentions sur ce sujet et savoir si
vous envisagez dans discuter avec la
grande maison à Bercy
surtout que ça ne coûte rien à l'état
merci beaucoup
puis Bernard buis merci présidente
madame la ministre d'abord vous faire
part d'un sentiment que j'ai puisque
vous avez parlé de la NCT et que vous
l'avez présidé avant votre prise de
fonction au gouvernement vous dire très
sereinement que j'ai l'impression que
c'est un machin qui a pas encore imprimé
au niveau des élus locaux je suis
convaincu je vois dans mon département
si j'appelle guymer il y en a 9 sur 10
qui me diront mais où est-ce qu'on peut
les joindre à quoi ça sert ce truc ça
paraît très nébuleux j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire à mon préfet voilà je pense
qu'il y a vraiment un effort à faire à
ce niveau là sinon alors ma question
était dans la Rémi Cointreau et la
présidente l'aborder qui concerne
effectivement la les programmes actions
au cœur de ville et petite ville pour
demain donc la semaine dernière on a eu
au sein de notre délégation en liaison
avec la délégation aux entreprises donc
la présentation de de conclusion d'un
rapport le même jour il y avait la Cour
des comptes qui qui présentait le
contrôle de ce programme
et ces deux rapports à la fois ici Sénat
et qu'on décompte mettez un peu la
déplorer un sous-financement un peu
chronique de de ce programme j'ai aussi
l'impression que quelque part finalement
il n'y a pas de financement dédié qu'on
utilise les crédits DETR des îles pour
pour aller sur ces programmes et que
c'est ça qui est amputé qui va être
amputé donc sur les demandes d'autres
collectivités alors comme je suis dans
un département où j'ai trois villes
actions au cœur de ville j'ai 14 villes
retenues au programme petite ville pour
moi voilà j'ai besoin voilà je suis très
attentif à l'évolution de l'évolution de
ces deux programmes et besoin que vous
nous éclairiez quand même un peu mieux
sur ces perspectives d'évolution que
vous comptez lui donner je vous remercie
merci présidente madame la ministre
d'abord une question et ensuite une
alerte ma question porte sur les maisons
et les bus France services m+c mis en
place depuis 2019 ces outils constituent
un nouveau modèle d'accès au service
public pour les Français l'objectif est
clair permettre à chaque citoyen quel
que soit l'endroit où il vit en zone
urbaine ou en zone rurale d'accéder au
service public et d'être accueillis dans
un lieu unique par des personnes formées
disponibles pour effectuer ces démarches
du quotidien des marchand
administratives liées à l'emploi la
santé la retraite etc ces maisons francs
services doivent permettre aux usagers
d'acquérir d'accéder à un bouquet de
service au sein d'un même lieu
l'objectif initial fixé à l'échéance
2022 prévoyez le déploiement de 2000
maisons francs services madame la
ministre pourriez-vous nous donner les
derniers chiffres dont vous disposez et
nous donner quelques indications sur la
pérennisation éventuelle du dispositif
et de son financement enfin une alerte à
propos d'une situation assez inédite je
sais pas si d'autres communes n'ont vécu
la Communauté des Communes du Val de
Drôme m'informent des difficultés
inquiétantes pour trouver une compagnie
d'assurance en matière de renouvellement
de contrat de responsabilité civile et
de protection juridique malgré un appel
d'offre ouvert aucune offre reçue il en
est de même pour les communes de Loriol
et de Livron la Communauté des Communes
a contacté cette assureur pas de réponse
aux réponses négatives au motif je cite
que due aux conditions drastiques
actuellement imposées par leur
réassureur une nouvelle offre est
impossible et qu'il en sera de même pour
nombreuses collectivités du Sud-Est bien
entendu madame la ministre une telle
impasse mais en danger des collectivités
dans un établissement je tenais donc à
profiter de votre venue au Sénat pour
vous alerter sur ce cas qui je l'espère
restera isolé
madame la mini je vous propose de
répondre ensuite en invitant mes
collègues
contenus de l'intensité de l'intérêt que
vous soulevez Madame le Ministre à ce
qu'on soit
consiste sinon si vous êtes d'accord si
on peut pas passer toutes les questions
nous prendrons toutes les questions de
nos collègues vous ne vous les
adresserons mais si on peut avoir cette
chose c'est mieux je vous en prie Madame
le Ministre
et interroger Stanislas Bouron sur
les
informations des ligibilité par la des
défis en fait il faudrait que ça soit
les services de Monsieur Attal qui
puisse répondre et qui dirige la DG Fire
et mais on passera le message pour voir
si ils peuvent d'ores et déjà annoncé
j'allais dire tous ceux qui peuvent
bénéficier du dispositif alors la
fameuse taxe d'aménagement
cette mesure visait à partager les
produits de cette taxe d'aménagement dès
lors que le PCI supporte un certain
nombre de charges de centralité et des
charges d'équipement public sur le
territoire de chaque commune membre
alors j'ai peut-être vous faire une
réponse
plus près de mon expérience mais je
pense que à l'intérieur de chaque
intercommunalité chaque agglo il doit y
avoir
j'allais dire une des échanges avec les
mers pour voir s'il y a un arbitrage que
l'on peut faire pour qu'il rentre qu'une
partie ou une moitié et que
éventuellement il y ait ils peuvent pas
rendre mais c'est l'agglo qui peut par
la une DSC une dotation de solidarité
communautaire qui peut faire
rendre un peu d'argent aux communes mais
c'est ça que je veux dire en fait les
communes sont obligées de d'obéir à la
loi mais dans le cadre d'une négociation
des dotations de solidarité il peut y
avoir une possibilité pour
l'agglomération mais on a on a
de solidarité des DSC non
obligation est légale mais s'ils le font
pas je crois que ça a été prévu une
espèce
oui mais on a un vrai sujet là-dessus
c'est-à-dire c'est une invention si une
invention un peu complique oui mais moi
j'assume à mon avis elle vient pas du
Sénat d'accord non non sauf que
rappelez-vous y compris en 3DS il
faisait participer au débat nous avons
instauré consolider l'idée de pacte
financiers au sein d'une interco et
excusez-moi quand on met dans la loi une
délibération là-dessus c'est renier la
libre administration des collectivités
locales et c'est au sein du pacte
financier que serait parti voilà mais
pour être très précise pour être très
précise la législation ne rentre pas
davantage dans les détails
laissant le soin aux élus concernés de
se concerter de se concerter pour
définir ensemble le taux à appliquer
donc il y a une marge de manœuvre
possible ensuite les délibérations qui
prévoit les conditions de versement de
tout ou partie tout ou partie du produit
de la taxe peuvent bien sûr être
modifiés à tout moment toutefois cela
doit se faire de façon concordante entre
la commune et le PCI donc je pense qu'il
y a enfin je pense je vais on va
vérifier mais je pense qu'il y a une
marge de manœuvre possible
le maximum parle et je voudrais
accélérer parce qu'on va pas traiter ça
là Charles
fiscalité additionnelle qui eux n'ont
pas de pacte
cependant
on ne leur permet pas de différencier au
sein d'une même commune un taux qui
serait relatif aux zones économiques et
au reste alors que le texte ne le
prévoit pas c'est tout simplement une
position administrative et qui empêche
toute l'attitude pour les élus et ça ça
fait deux fois que je lance laserte et
on me dit c'est l'environnement et
l'urbanisme c'est pas nous mais il faut
quand même faire quelque chose
auprès de du cabinet de Gabriel Attal il
y a beaucoup d'excitation sur le sujet
alors je pense la parole j'ai pas
répondu à coeur de vie pardon excuse-moi
pardon
monsieur le sénateur de l'Isère je vais
avoir le plaisir le 15 octobre de venir
dans votre département à l'assemblée
générale des mers puisque j'ai été
invité ce matin et que j'ai répondu
favorablement voilà donc
je vais être interpellé mais je peux
d'ores et déjà vous dire quand même que
il y a aujourd'hui
234 villes qui bénéficient qui ont
bénéficié du programme Action coeur de
ville 1 et que le Jean Castex avait
autorisé à ce que le dispositif soit
prolongé jusqu'en 2026
l'avantage de ce dispositif c'est aussi
évidemment
d'améliorer l'offre de logements de
développer les commerces de centre-ville
de venir en aide sur le patrimoine avec
un dispositif
Malraux ville moyenne si je puis dire et
aujourd'hui d'avoir d'être signataire
d'une
Ort
c'est une c'est un dispositif qui est
jeune il est arrivé grâce au sénateur en
janvier
un mois avant la crise du covid qui a
été rendu difficile finalement à la fois
les responsabilités l'exercice des
responsabilités du directeur qui était
le préfet Yves Le Breton mais qui je
dois le dire a beaucoup relancé les mers
les députés voilà la pardon les préfets
de départements qui sont les délégués
territoriaux de la NCT et donc avec lui
au gré des confinements pendant l'année
2020-2021 je suis allé dans des
départements
régulièrement une fois par semaine pour
à la fois présenter le programme ou pour
inaugurer des projets comme je suis
allée en Ille-et-Vilaine
inaugurer un bus France service on
pourra en reparler mais sur le terrain
aujourd'hui les 5 milliards qui étaient
mis sur la table avec nos partenaires
qui sont la banque des territoires
actions logements Lana et évidemment
l'état il y a quasiment les 5 milliards
à la fin de l'année auront été investis
et donc nous allons avancer sur un
programme
non pas identique puisqu'il va rester
quatre ans mais quasi identique et ce
sera officialisé par la première
ministre à la fin du mois d'octobre au
début du mois de novembre le programme
Action coeur de ville 2
l'originalité de ce dispositif c'est
quand même qu'il a été co-construit
alors avec Jacques mesard et Jacqueline
Gouraud et moi-même quand j'étais
président de l'association des villes
moyennes et ça n'a jamais répondu à des
appels à projets c'était les qui
déposait leurs projets les faisaient
valider à l'agence alors pourtant nous
avons fait une newsletter pourtant nous
avons beaucoup communiqué sur l'action
de la NCT je le dis devant Stanislas
Bouron qui est en commissaire du
gouvernement au sein de la NCT visait
nos conseils d'administration
mais sans doute on peut être perfectible
j'ose espérer que la nouvelle équipe
sera à la hauteur de ces programmes et
je suis prête à le détailler un peu plus
la semaine prochaine quand je viendrai
alors je n'ai pas compris si c'était à
Grenoble ou si c'était
pardon
oui d'accord très bien donc sur petite
ville de demain je dois reconnaître les
choses ne sont pas aussi dynamiques que
sur action cœur de ville que nous allons
les intensifier les programmes et
pour mettre aux communes de cette taille
d'aller plus loin dans l'exercice de ce
programme dans la mise en oeuvre de ce
programme je suis allée aussi dans
certains départements où j'ai pu visiter
des petites villes et là aussi je trouve
que sur certaines où je suis allée les
réponses ont été plutôt efficaces mais
je sais aussi que tout n'est pas parfait
et donc voilà je nous ferons en sorte
que ce programme là soit dynamisé sur
les maisons France services nous sommes
quasiment
j'allais dire aux objectifs qui avaient
été accès à savoir 2500 maisons francs
services à la fin de 2022 il y en a
2397 si je 79 si je ne me trompe pas
donc nous sommes quasiment à l'objectif
en sachant que la 2500e devrait être
finalisée au mois de novembre puisque
nous avons un certain nombre de demandes
le but était que la majorité des
Français pour ne pas dire 100% des
Français se trouve à moins de 30 minutes
d'une maison France service et 93% à
moins de 20 minutes d'une maison francs
services alors je sais que certaines
sont plus efficaces que d'autres que les
partenaires que ce soit
les impôts Pôle emploi la MSA
la Poste sont présents pas partout pas
aussi régulièrement qu'on le
souhaiterait j'ai il y a des initiatives
tout à fait efficaces avec
les bus France services dont d'ailleurs
certains départements se sont servis
pour les vaccinations pour aller au plus
près des habitants donc je crois que
vraiment les bus France services ou les
maisons françaises sont un programme qui
est mis en œuvre avec efficacité à
travers les départements et que les
objectifs
sont
vont être atteints voilà il y a
peut-être sans doute des ajustements et
des améliorations mais il faudra compter
sur les préfets de chaque département
pour attirer notre attention sur ce qui
ne va pas je voudrais saluer le
directeur de la NCT
François Antoine Mariani peut-être plus
spécialisé dans la politique de la ville
mais néanmoins bien afin connaisseur des
dispositifs qui sont mis en œuvre
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y avait d'autre
comme question
importante alors
consciente malheureusement vous n'êtes
pas le seul élu à nous en faire part
donc on va travailler là-dessus et
essayer de
solliciter les compagnies d'assurance et
les assureurs parce que c'est à la fois
indécent et totalement
délicat pour tous les élus mais vous
êtes vraiment pas le premier
malheureusement à tirer mon attention
sur ce sujet donc on va s'en occuper et
je reviendrai vers vous par un courrier
monsieur le sénateur pour vous donner
des informations et j'ai donnerai aussi
à Françoise Gatel merci Madame la
Ministre donc
ah oui Lausanne j'en ai pas parlé
[Musique]
plus de 63000 hectares de forêts entiers
ravagés ces épisodes sont amenés à se
répéter et donc il faut absolument
renforcer la sécurité civile par des
formations par par des moyens et aussi
des pilotes d'avion qui doivent être
formés notre sécurité civile doit être
aussi moderniser à l'instar de ce que
propose les autorités européennes qui
s'apprêtent à redimensionner la capacité
du mécanisme de protection civile de
l'Union européenne et la flotte de
transition européenne devrait aussi être
doublée dès l'année prochaine en
attendant l'entrée en service d'une
véritable flotte permanente entre 2026
et 2030 donc c'est pas demain c'est
plutôt après-demain donc dans l'attente
il faut vraiment qu'on active les moyens
madame la ministre que proposez-vous
pour renforcer moderniser notre système
de protection civile face à la multiplie
merci présidente madame la ministre
voudrait appuyer ce qu'a dit la prise de
glatel sur la nécessité d'indexer la DGF
sur l'inflation parce qu'effectivement
nous connaissons un contexte tout à fait
exceptionnel et puis parce que la DGF
est nous nous le rappelons chaque fois
que nécessaire n'est pas une subvention
de l'État à l'égard des collectivités
mais compense des missions que les
collectivités assument
et que ça doit rester cela et je pense
que ça aussi du sens à ce titre là plus
précisément je voudrais vous interpeller
sur l'obligation qui va être faite à
partir de 2023 de lier les taux de taxes
sur le foncier bâti à celui de la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires je crois que c'est issu de
la du PLF 2020 et c'est un sujet de
préoccupation notamment pour les
littoral qui lutte contre je sais pas
comment le dire mais contre l'expansion
on va dire de l'habitat et des
résidences secondaires qui surenchérit
les coûts enfin les prix du l'immobilier
qui empêche des jeunes du coup ou des
salariés qui viennent travailler de
s'installer et il me semblerait
utile pour aider les élus locaux à
lutter contre ces phénomènes de délier
ces deux taxes pour que on puisse
augmenter la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires sans impacter des
propriétaires modestes dans un contexte
où c'est un des derniers leviers en plus
pour les collectivités depuis la
disparition de la taxe d'habitation
merci et c'est pour ce qui est plus une
recommandation qu'une question mais une
excellente recommandation Laurent merci
Madame la madame la ministre j'aimerais
vous interroger sur un sujet sur lequel
nous débattons beaucoup les
ordinateur et sénatrice sur lequel
peut-être ce débat va encore continuer
dans les semaines à venir c'est sur la
compétence soit assainissement et son
transfert ou non aux EPCI pour vous
faire part un message des des élus
gardois des petites communes vous nous
demandant vous demandant à ce qu'ils
aient le choix de transfert dans cette
compétence beaucoup d'élus me disent
monsieur sénateur parce que j'ai
rencontré si on a plus ce choix mais
demain nous ne représenterons plus aux
élections municipales et on nous
risquons avoir un déficit démocratique
c'est-à-dire plus de candidats à des
élections municipales des petites
communes parce qu'autrement ils auront
pas le choix de leur avenir à travers
cette compétence ou assainissement donc
Madame ministre vous venez de dire que
vous avez la volonté de mettre en place
une politique publique différenciée
est-ce que vous seriez prêt
à rouvrir ce débat là en écoutant et à
mettre en place cette politique
différenciée en laissant au choix aux
élus de leur avenir par rapport à cette
compétence
marronnier sénatoriale
aimer a raison il fait l'objet d'une PPL
qui a été déposée et voilà je sais que
Monsieur le Directeur de la DGCL à tous
l'historique de nos conversations madame
la ministre
alors je vais répondre d'abord à
Patricia Sillinger pour lui dire que oui
la saison cette année a été dramatique
puisqu'il y a eu près de 72000 hectares
qui est d'espace naturel qui ont été
brûlés je crois qu'il faut aussi rendre
hommage à l'engagement des forces de
sécurité civile 10.000 sapeurs-pompiers
par jour en moyenne avec un pic à 40000
dans les Landes et en Gironde
au total il y a eu 60000 personnes aussi
qui ont été évacuées et heureusement il
n'y a eu aucun mort
déploré que ce soit chez les pompiers ou
que ce soit chez les habitants et puis
je voudrais aussi évidemment ici saluer
le rôle des élus locaux que j'ai croisé
sans certains déplacements qui ont été
absolument exemplaires alors vous savez
que plusieurs initiatives ont été
lancées et le président de la République
veut réunir les acteurs de la sécurité
civile à la fin du mois d'octobre et je
suis chargée de préparer cette réunion
en recevant tous ceux qui contribuent de
près ou de loin à la sécurité civile
voire même pompier volontaire pompier
professionnel et tous les pilotes qui
ont aussi des choses à dire sur le
matériel je suis allée à Bruxelles
défendre aussi la position de la France
et remercier aussi pour la solidarité
les pays qui sont nous sont venus en
aide la Grèce nous étions allés en Grèce
l'année dernière et puis d'autres pays
européens qui nous ont apporté
leur soutien je pense qu'il faudra
réfléchir et c'est l'objet des débats
que je mène en ce moment sur peut-être
un nouveau modèle de la sécurité civile
ce sont en tout cas
à certains nombre de conclusions que je
pourrais transmettre au président de la
République
sachez néanmoins que les préfets font
partie aussi à la fois de leur rôle
de travailler avec la sécurité civile
dans le cadre de la prise et puis nous
allons assister aussi beaucoup sur la
prévention puisqu'il y a un modèle
méditerranéen qui est particulièrement
efficace et donc ce matin d'ailleurs
j'interrogeais ce qui était en face de
moi les acteurs qui étaient en face de
moi pour savoir comment transposer en le
territorialisant bien sûr le modèle
méditerranéen qui permettait qui
permettait de protéger ou surtout de
réagir très vite puisque j'ai compris
que si dans la demi-journée le feu
n'était pas
circonscrit c'était venait très
difficile après de lutter et de gagner
cette bataille donc ce qu'il faut c'est
lutter contre les le naissant et c'est
évidemment ce que nous allons faire deux
mots sur le matériel il y a des
commandes de
d'avions qui sont faites mais qui est
des Canadairs malheureusement il y a un
problème de matériel puisque c'est
commandé aussi au niveau européen et
ils seront pas livrés avant 2026 donc la
réflexion qui est menée c'est de comment
gérer depuis 2023 2026 donc voilà les
grandes lignes de ce dossier sécurité
civile sur lequel nous travaillons avec
Gérald Darmanin d'une manière
approfondie
ensuite il y avait monsieur
la fiscalité des résidences secondaires
mais j'ai oublié non c'est vous oui non
mais j'ai ça bon
les collectivités peuvent majorer la
taxe d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires pour ato compris entre 5% et
60% dès lors qu'elles sont situées et
c'est là le souci dans une zone tendue
bon tendu ça représente à peu près 233
communes qui l'ont fait en 2021 pour un
montant de 136 millions d'euros ce
zonage correspond à celui de la taxe sur
les logements vacants
qui est perçu par l'État et en dehors de
ces zonage les collectivités peuvent la
créer cette taxe d'habitation sur les
logements vacants donc ça c'est à
l'initiative des municipalités alors
évidemment il y a des demandes de
révision de zonage sur lesquels nous
serons obligés peut-être de travailler
et de revenir
c'est une demande récurrente aussi des
communes du littoral et je suis allée à
leur congrès la semaine dernière et
évidemment le sujet a été mis sur la
table donc c'est une réflexion certaines
le souhaitent pas d'autres le souhaitent
voilà c'est
j'espère qu'on pourra sortir de cette
difficulté pour les communes
et puis il y avait la loi notre sur
l'eau et l'assainissement c'est ça
bon alors j'ai compris tout de suite que
c'était aussi une ligne rouge au CEA
quand Gérard Larcher le président m'a
reçu à la fin du mois d'août
c'est compréhensible quelque part que se
transfère suscite encore des réticences
dans une partie du bloc communal compte
tenu de l'importance de la compétence
haut en tant que service essentiel et de
proximité
de même que les départements n'ont plus
de compétences directes dans ce domaine
et ne peuvent intervenir qu'un
directement puisque ce sont les
communautés d'agglomération ou une
intercommunalité qui doivent s'en
charger depuis 2015 il y a plusieurs
aménagements qui ont été effectués sur
le plan du calendrier sur le plan d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs
transitoire des contraintes et des
préoccupations locales toutefois je vais
quand même vous dire les choses
clairement la loi 3DS à prolonger les la
situation jusqu'en 2026 c'est le délai
le dernier délai de transfert pour
faciliter le transfert en donnant du
temps au collectivités je sais que c'est
un double défi écologique et financier
mais je peux vous dire que je crains
qu'on ne revienne pas sur cette échéance
de 2026
ce sujet il faut je pense qu'on a du mal
à se faire comprendre il ne s'agit pas
de dire que l'eau doit être gérée à
l'échelle de la commune mais personne
n'a vu de l'eau coulée dans un périmètre
administratif l'eau suit le bassin
versant et chez moi j'ai l'exemple d'un
bassin versant sur trois départements et
que donc l'idée c'est de permettre que
soit géré une échelle pertinente mais
que au lieu d'artificiellement la
commune donne la compétence à l'interco
qui envoie des délégués et le délégué
n'est pas intéressé alors que c'est la
commune l'idée encore une fois c'est
l'efficacité la pertinence donc 100 fois
sur le métier remettez votre ouvrage
nous on y est depuis 2016 je pense que
vraiment on a un super sujet là-dessus
il faut que chacun comprenne ce
phénomène physique de l'eau qui coule
selon les bassins versants
merci je passe la parole à Laurent
saumon Bernard delcro et Sonia de la
pauvreté et ensuite il nous restera
trois collègues et puis un moment zan on
va faire une pause zen Laurent
même la présidente madame la ministre ça
va être un peu redondant mais pas tant
que ça ça va prendre d'autres exemples
moi je crois que l'ingérence permanente
effectivement de l'État dans les
compétences dans la gestion des
collectivités ne laisse plus cette
autonomie de gestion telle qu'elle était
connue comme la démontré le débat qu'on
a eu sur la taxe d'aménagement on voit
pertinemment que si on avait un dialogue
serein au niveau des collectivités
locales l'État n'a pas besoin de s'en
mêler on peut trouver largement les
solutions les communes qui en plus ont
la clause de compétences générale mais
dont on enlève complètement les
capacités financières et les
intercommunalités à qui on redonne des
compétences supplémentaires et qui
doivent trouver les recettes et donc
créer de nouveaux impôts on a parlé donc
de je vais en citer deux c'est bien sûr
la compétence assainissement sur
laquelle se désengage en plus les
agences de l'eau
en tout cas sur l'assainissement non
collectif en particulier
c'est aussi le cas de la compétence
j'aime ma pièce c'est sur celle là que
je voulais insister la compétence des
Mappy qui comme vient de le dire à la
présidentielle n'est pas je dirais une
question de circonscription
administrative c'est bien là un bassin
ou voir un fleuve donc plusieurs bassins
hydrographiques qui alimentent ce fleuve
et j'ai rencontré la semaine dernière
une commune petite commune 76 habitants
qui dans l'interco noyé dans
l'intercommunalité ce qui d'ailleurs met
des tensions entre communes et
intercommunalités se retrouvent à
appliquer donc la taxe gemapi pour
lequel elle n'a quasiment aucun bénéfice
sans que pour autant la taxe gemapi
puisse les aider à traiter ce qui
contribue aussi aux inondations
c'est-à-dire le traitement de la de la
de des eaux de ruissellement et
l'érosion des sols
ça c'est quand même inadmissible qu'il
n'y ait pas la possibilité que à tout le
bassin puisse bénéficier d'une taxe sur
tous les items et pas seulement sur
certains items qui sont dans le cadre de
la taxe gemapi donc c'était un peu ça
que je voulais je voulais dire et puis
j'insiste aussi sur un pour être assez
court un deuxième point les communes
aujourd'hui vont avoir des grandes
difficultés avec la sécheresse qui s'est
passé et notamment les affaissements de
terrain et en particulier sur les
infrastructures qui ne peut ne sont pas
assurées et donc qui ne peuvent pas
bénéficier du fond Barnier quid de la
possibilité pour ces communes d'avoir
des subventions au titre du fond Barnier
revisité ou éventuellement des deetr ou
autres financement de l'État
l'engagement et proximité n'a pas suffi
Bernard merci et puis merci madame la
ministre pour pour ces échanges alors je
vous parlerai pas des adriens bien
entendu sur la DGF sur la sur la DGF
en responsabilité il faut concilier deux
nécessités
à tenir les camps de l'État redresser
les cornes de l'État et je pense que la
ligne du 5% de déficit maximum il faut
la tenir et en même temps donner aux
collectivités les moyennes d'agir et si
on veut trouver un équilibre entre les
deux je pense pour ce qui est pour ce
qui me concerne que ça suppose des
mesures qui soient ciblées pour aider
des collectivités qui en ont le plus
besoin de manière efficace d'ailleurs il
faut le faire à tout ça en tenant compte
du fait que pour les collectivités qui
vont percevoir leur part de TVA et elles
sont
nombreuses maintenant
on va être dans une dynamique de TVA
entre 9 et 10%, c'est bien compris donc
voilà donc il faut des mesures ciblées
de ce point de vue là
de la DSR des su
cible bien les collectivités qui en ont
besoin par définition
dans 210 millions sont prévus qui sont
pas prises pour la première fois
d'ailleurs sur l'enveloppe des Gets donc
qui viennent en plus sinon ça faisait au
détriment évidemment de la DGF
forfaitaire pour l'ensemble des communes
je pense que compte tenu de la situation
de certaines collectivités de certaines
communes je rappelle que les communes ne
perçoivent pas de part de TVA d'ailleurs
je pense qu'il faut peut-être discuter
sur ce montant de 210 millions en tous
les cas c'est la bonne méthode de cibler
sur les communes qui en ont besoin et ça
va aussi évidemment pour on va dire le
bouclier énergétique pour faire simple
pour 2023 bien regarder les communes qui
sont concernées qui ont besoin d'être
d'être d'être aidé sur la dotation
biodiversité je vais pas y revenir mais
vous connaissez un point de vue c'est
une belle avancée on a franchi une
première marche il faut aller plus loin
et je voudrais relativiser les chiffres
ont augmentation mais on est en train de
parler de 30 millions d'euros au total
pour la dotation biodiversité on n'est
pas en train de parler de milliards je
pourrais mettre en parallèle les 8
milliards de CVAE donc c'est parce qu'on
demande mais en tous les cas je pense
qu'il faut vraiment booster la dotation
biodiversité c'est une belle
reconnaissance des immunités rurales ça
fait longtemps qu'on demandait peut-être
élargir son assiette je reviens pas
là-dessus pour parce que on n'a pas le
temps en tous les cas ça fait partie des
sujets importants que booster sur les
investissements donc j'ai une remarque
et une question donc on a notre DETR qui
a été réformé qui marche plutôt bien la
décide qui avait été créée et puis et
puis le fond vert de 1,5 milliards juste
j'allais sur une chose mais on avait eu
l'occasion d'en parler la DETR doit
rester une dotation aux collectivités
rurales interco et commune qui reste
assez souple avec une programmation
annuelle en s'adaptant aux besoins des
collectivités dans les territoires et
donc il faut faire attention je sais que
le risque existe parce que la DETR soit
pas tout à coup
rencontrer ou fléchés systématiquement
sur les CRPE ou intégrer dans des
programmations plus réelles de crpe même
si je
même si sur un projet je peux cumuler
les deux ça c'est bien c'est pas ça que
je remets encore une collectivité peut
très bien demander un complément DETR
c'est pas la même chose que programmer
de la DETR dans un certain dans une
programmation plus réelle et de se
retrouver de faire ça au détriment des
autres communes donc je voudrais bien
reparler si vous si vous le voulez en
tous les cas c'est pas du tout la même
chose je suis pas contre le fait qu'on
puisse cumuler la décile la DETR c'est
pas le sujet ou vers le programme petite
ville de demain d'ailleurs il faut faire
attention de trouver les équilibres et
de pas la concentrer sur une programme
précis au détriment au détriment des
autres et donc du coup je sais qu'il
faut se fasse vite
Françoise sur le fond vert donc pas
d'appel à projet c'est très bien et
est-ce que l'idée c'est comme la décide
d'avoir des enveloppes déléguées préfet
de région où ça reste une enveloppe
nationale
la réponse l'a fait quoi en région
alors nous on aimerions préférée nous on
aimerait bien que ça préfère département
je parle
mais c'est un peu le vœu que je forme en
tous les cas vous avez notre soutien
pour que ça aille vers les prophètes
départements je parle au nom des
collègues je ne sais pas si voilà et
puis dernier point sur l'ingénierie il y
a eu des mesures intéressantes de prix
sur l'ingénierie chef de projet PVD
conseiller numérique VTA etc mais sur
des court terme il faut quand même qu'on
donne aux élus de la visibilité sur le
long terme donc je pense qu'il faut
arriver à trouver des mécanismes qui
donnent plus qui inscrivent ces soutien
à l'ingénierie dans dans la durée voilà
et puis pour les normes simplement pour
dire qu'il faut qu'il y ait un ventre il
faut qu'il invente ce briété qui souffre
sur les Noirs c'est ça
que beaucoup d'humour alors je suis
vraiment confuse après je suis très
heureuse de cet échange et de la
richesse et qui tient vos vous voyez la
qualité des questions et des
questionnaires des questionneurs je
devrais vous quitter à 18h55 je suis
navrée mais qu'est-ce que j'ai dit 17h55
merci beaucoup Charles Guénet va assumer
la présidente avec brio et nous avons
promis un temps Zam qui sera intégrés
dans les questions je crois c'est Sonia
qui va initier les choses donc vous me
pardonnerez madame la ministre si je
file à l'anglaise c'est sans sans aucune
et respect amitié voilà
vas-y viens
bon donc je reprends le fil de ces
choses nous avons encore trois
intervenants mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'avant auparavant madame la ministre
puisse répondre
de bassin versant vous pouvez les avoir
par l'intermédiaire de la DDT en CDC
bon et ensuite la détermination des EPCI
qui doivent gérer quelque part
donc c'est une interco qui gère
mais il y a des syndicats à l'heure
actuelle qui
délègue un syndicat
alors bon moi sur le gemapi la science
infuse sur ce truc là
mais
quand il y a plusieurs connaissances de
la préoccupation qui relève des
collectivités mais on sait que ça se
traite aussi de manière
interministérielle mais nous on a une
obsession qui parfois est justifiée sur
ce sujet voilà je referai un schéma
précis mais la seule chose faut pas
rêver on reviendra pas sur 20 le délai
de 2026
malheureusement
alors sur le qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
d'autre
est-ce qu'il y avait d'autres
c'était tout la DGF non la DETR
il y a une commission d'élus dans la
DETR donc de toute façon vous y
participez enfin vos élus
y participent il y a pas de fléchage
d'enveloppe
voilà
oui il y avait aussi un point
particulier c'était l'éligibilité au
fond Barnier des collectivités pour des
infrastructures qui ne sont pas
assurables
à l'instant T sur le zan non c'était ça
[Musique]
simplement puisque
tu as fini
sur le sujet au assainissement qu'on a
évoqué j'ai juste me permettre une
petite remarque parce que j'ai la
Présidente je peux
non je n'abuse pas
simplement je pense que de depuis que le
dialogue existe entre la suppression ou
pas de il y a eu de grandes avancées qui
permettent des tas de choses possibles
au niveau des communes et je pense qu'il
serait bien de les mettre à plat et d'en
faire l'inventaire de façon à
démystifier un peu je veux dire la chose
c'est un conseil que je donnerais mais
bon bref je dis ça parce que je
travaille sur le sujet et je m'aperçois
qu'en fait on peut faire des choses
alors simplement il nous reste trois
intervenants et alors comme je dois
suivre l'ordre proposé par la Présidente
je pense que Lausanne arrivera en
deuxième Catherine tu interviens pas sur
Lausanne toi non je me demande si tu
aurais pas intérêt à intervenir avant le
sujet du zones bon alors Dominique
avant et je ferai intervenir Catherine
avant pour qu'on termine sur le zan si
vous me le permettez
voilà de toute façon sur les ânes je
crois la présidente a quand même brossé
le tableau moi je voulais vous
interroger madame la ministre sur les
aoh les autorités organisatrices de
l'habitat elles ont été créées par la
loi 3DS sur un amendement que j'avais
proposé en ma qualité de rapporteur qui
avait été voté contre la vie avec un
avis défavorable du gouvernement pour
autant elles sont restées dans le texte
définitif dans le cadre de la commission
mixte paritaire et ces aoha elles sont
calcées sur le modèle des autorités
organisatrices de la mobilité les aomes
et elles permettent donc aux EPCI d'être
éligibles et surtout ce qui est
important c'est qu'elle vise
véritablement à articuler les politiques
nationales du logement avec les
spécificités des territoires je pense
que vraiment sur le sujet du logement on
a vraiment besoin de pouvoir s'adapter
au mieux aux spécificités du territoire
d'éviter de locale parce que la France
du logement mais bon cette bien d'autres
sujets qui sont dans le même situation
elle se caractérise bien sûr par des
situations qui sont très hétérogènes
alors cette capacité d'adaptation aux
politiques locales elle est souhaitable
je pense par exemple à la rénovation
énergétique ma prime rénove aujourd'hui
c'est quand même pas un succès
extraordinaire même si le gouvernement
mais je pense que si ma prime rénove
était décentralisée à l'échelle des
territoires je pense que les résultats
n'en seraient que meilleur comme on a
délégué un moment donné les aides à la
pierre de faire en sorte que sur la
rénovation énergétique où on a vraiment
besoin de sortir du geste par geste pour
aller vers la rénovation globale
performante je pense que et ça serait
possible dans le cadre d'une Awash sur
ma prime rénove mais aussi sur les
locations saisonnières alors je sais
qu'il y a un certain nombre de
métropoles qui commencent à se saisir de
statut je crois qu'il y a la métropole
de Brest qui a été donc déclaré par le
préfet premier organisatrice de
l'habitat à Rennes enfin donc il y a un
certain nombre de métropoles pour autant
aujourd'hui ces Awash elles ont le
bénéfice d'avoir un statut mais elle
reste une coquille vide parce que voilà
à l'intérieur c'est encore trop récent
donc comment vous verriez vous évoluer
ce cadre-là est-ce que vous seriez
favorable à ce qu'il y ait aussi à
l'intérieur du nawash la possibilité de
trouver des moyens de financement à
travers des moyennes financement de la
décentralisation pour que à l'instar
desaèmes où il y a un versement
transport il puisse y avoir demain dans
le cadre des autorités organisatrices de
l'habitat aussi une ressource propre qui
permette véritablement à ce moment-là de
faire de véritables politiques de
décentralisation du logement dans les
territoires qui se seront portés
candidats
merci
peut-être on prend la question de
Catherine noisier on prendra aux deux
questions avant de taquer les merci
monsieur le Président Madame la mairie
très rapidement moi je voulais juste
rebondir sur vos propos tout à l'heure
madame lamis sur la DFC sur le modèle
méditerranéen juste pour vous dire qu'en
fait le modèle il correspond à une
réalité bien spécifique des territoires
méditerranéens et vraiment je vous
invite à regarder le rapport que nous
avons réalisé pour le compte de la
commission d'affaires économiques et de
la commission développement durages pour
prévenir l'embrasement des espaces
naturels et je pense que ce serait
vraiment une erreur de penser que le
modèle méditerranéen est transposable
dans l'ensemble du territoire puisque
c'est pas du tout le cas et mon autre
question on m'a question rapidement
c'est je vais pas parler du je vais
parler français mais pas d'usane mais de
la SNAP la stratégie nationale des aires
protégées pour laquelle il s'avère
aujourd'hui que les DREAL commencent à
phosphorer et faire des zonages
sans forcément y associer sont
d'ailleurs y associer du tout à ma
connaissance des collectivités
et notamment les communes et que dans le
viseur on a beaucoup de forêts
communales mon cher collègue Charles
gagné on connaît ce sujet là sur notre
parc national des forêts donc voilà je
voulais savoir est-ce que c'est commune
pourront demain prétendre elle aussi à
une dotation biodiversité
au titre de ces airs protégés je
rappelle quand même que la stratégie
nationale c'est 30% en protection 30% du
territoire national en protection et 10%
en protection forte donc il faudrait pas
qu'on nous refasse un scénario Natura
2000 parce que ça risque de se mâle se
présenter voilà donc un sujet qui
préoccupe beaucoup aujourd'hui dans les
territoires merci Madame la Ministre
sachant que si le sujet est trop pointu
on rencontre Monsieur Béchu le 19 qui
est plus sur cette rubrique donc comme
au lait sur ces deux questions
méditerranéen pour la sécurité civile
nous n'envisageons absolument pas à
copier coller sauf que l'entretien des
forêts ou des parties boisées depuis un
certain nombre d'années particulièrement
bien fait et si les incendies ont pris
de telles proportions en Gironde c'est
parce que c'était des forêts privées
usagères qu'on appelle usagère et qui
n'avait pas été entretenu et donc même
les pompiers n'arrivaient pas à circuler
à l'intérieur avec des problématiques de
logement qui n'auraient sans doute pas
dû être là où ils sont donc en fait
c'est une prévention dans l'esprit de ce
qui a été fait dans le midi mais c'est
évidemment pas un copier-coller qui est
envisagé voilà
non elle ressemble pas mais le fait le
fait de prévenir d'entretenir et de
surveiller les permis de construire sont
quand même sont des sujets de
préoccupation
sur
la dotation biodiversité le périmètre de
cette dotation
elle évolue presque chaque année et donc
il faut évidemment
évaluer l'intérêt et le coût d'extension
à de nouveaux périmètres
au-delà des zones Natura 2000 et des
et des Parcs Naturels donc cette année
il y a une augmentation mais il faut
sans doute peut-être améliorer aussi les
le soutien que l'État peut apporter à
ces zones privilégiées quelque part mais
avec des contraintes aussi qui sont
importantes sur l'environnement sur le
logement dans ces parties là
alors madame Estrosi ça sonne je
reconnais là sa grande compétence en
matière de logement c'est une
spécialiste alors il y a une réflexion
qui est lancée sur les aoh elle a
demande du Président de la République
pour
l'organisation des compétences logement
alors je suis pas ministre du Logement
c'est Olivier Klein ça vous aura sans
doute pas échappé
il y a beaucoup de sujets à discuter
au-delà de la prime rénove avec l'aide à
la pierre vous l'avez dit avec le DALO
avec l'hébergement d'urgence
et donc dans le cadre de cette réflexion
le renforcement du rôle des aoh
évidemment sera envisagé
mais moi je peux pas vous en dire plus à
l'instant où on se parle je préviendrai
Olivier Klein qui faut qu'il m'envoie
une réponse plus circonstanciée qui sera
là avec nous le 17 novembre
je finis sur le zan on va finir
peut-être mais on va laisser Sonia de la
pauvreté pour poser sa question et
peut-être nous présenter son merci
Madame c'est compliqué de poser une
question sur le Zam dans tant il y a de
doute et d'interrogations dans la tête
des élus et particulièrement des élus
ruraux mais pas que mais pas que
et notamment aussi au niveau de de
nos collaborateurs qui travaillent dans
les structures d'ingénierie parce que on
n'a pas tout à fait les clés pour
calculer la consommation puisqu'on sait
pas ce qu'on consomme on sait pas avec
précision ce qui a nectar artificialisé
ou pas on a demandé à ce que les décrets
sortis qui
sont quand même pas simples pas tout à
fait simple pas tout à fait en phase en
tout cas avec la réalité des terrains et
avec cette fameuse territorialisation
qui était quand même un peu le le grand
gain du travail
parlementaire sur la loi
et donc c'est d'écrire on a demandé à ce
que a de lever le pied un peu le
ministre en tout cas
l'a dit et en fait on a on a des vrais
problèmes la seule chose que
souhaiterait les élus en l'état actuel
des choses c'est de desserrer un peu le
calendrier parce que comment estimer une
enveloppe à l'échelle régionale d'abord
au niveau local puis à l'échelle
régionale parce que si ça remonte des
territoires ou des scottes avec la
Conférence régionale des scottes mais
des intercommunalités qui sont parfois à
cheval enfin etc etc sur plusieurs Scots
comment on fait pour remonter des
hectares artificialisés quand on sait
pas
ce qu'on a à estimer à calculer à
évaluer à corriger ça c'est la première
chose et la deuxième chose
comment on fait pour
considérer que les projets portés sont
consommateurs ou pas c'est à dire que il
y a pas de définition légale de la
friche donc on est on sait pas si on est
sur de la fraîche ou pas de la
rénovation urbaine en matière de deux
artificialisation on considère un
certain nombre de terrains qui sont
pourtant des terrains vagues mais qu'on
considère comme étant artificialisé et
en fait il y a un vrai hiatus parce que
par rapport aux générations de documents
d'urbanisme cette planification qui se
sont mis en place avec cette recherche
de de d'optimiser finalement et de moins
construire sur sur des terres agricoles
et pas que sur sur les sur les terrains
Hénaf on a cherché on a traqué les dents
creuse on a travaillé sur les stocks on
a travaillé enfin surtout un tas de
sujets on nous a demandé avec les trames
vertébrés de protéger les fonds de
jardin pour avoir des continuités
écologiques des trames vertes etc et
pour maintenir la biodiversité
biodiversité qui fait partie des
critères prioritaires des quatre
critères propriétaires prioritaires qui
ont été évoqués et donc ça mi bout à
bout la question je vais pas vous faire
la fronde vous poser une question mais
simplement une alerte pour vous dire que
la mauvaise volonté n'est pas forcément
là au contraire je crois qu'il y a
vraiment une envie de comprendre et
d'appréhender ces sujets mais le couteau
sous la gorge entre guillemets c'est à
dire vraiment avec un calendrier
intenable une complexité absolue de ce
qui sort et de ce qui est proposé et
finalement une territorialisation qui ne
serait que de façade parce que les
contraintes telles et la complexité
telle ferait que les élus seraient
réduits à décider sur la portion congrue
de ce qui reste pour traiter la question
d'usane dans leur document de
planification voilà c'est l'esprit du
terrain que je vous rapporte vous le
connaissez
alors sur le zan je voudrais vous dire
plusieurs choses tout d'abord nous
sommes conscients avec Christophe Béchu
de la difficulté de la complexité de ce
dossier et nous souhaitons que l'État et
les collectivités soient vraiment
partenaires il a adressé une lettre à
chaque préfet en leur demandant de lever
le crayon comme il dit parce que nous
avons lancé des études d'urbanisme dont
nous aurons le rendu à la fin de l'année
pour revenir devant devant les élus à
l'instant où on se parle nous avons
obtenu la validation de neutraliser les
projets d'intérêt national et d'intérêts
régional dont les trajectoires zanes
locales donc ça c'est quand même une
avancée et je vais me tourner vers le
sénateur de l'Oise je fais allusion par
exemple
au canal senor qui représente 2200
hectares de terre
seront donc sortis des évaluations qu'il
reste à consommer mais il peut y avoir
en plus une voie ferrée il peut y avoir
d'autres équipements on voudrait aussi
que les autoroutes sortent des de ces
calculs et que ça soit plus clair
néanmoins les collectivités nous
souhaitons qu'elles soient accompagnées
avec la poursuite du fond friche qui va
permettre de qui sera qui est mis en
place avec un fond de restauration
le rôle accrue des EPF je pense que là
aussi c'est important
la mobilisation du fond vert et puis je
dirais la mobilisation d'outils
d'ingénierie à la fois pour donner les
fournir les données nécessaires et pour
accompagner les collectivités je pense
et je reviens à la NCT la mobilisation
du Serena par exemple qui peut être très
importante ce qu'on va rester sur une
une
approche
territorialisée mais fallait des
régionales si j'ai bien de toute façon
on n'a pas le choix mais ce qu'on veut
c'est pas pénaliser le secteur rural
parce qu'on est bien conscient que ne
plus pouvoir construire dans une commune
rurale ça veut dire moins d'habitants ce
qui veut dire une école qui s'essouffle
et donc moins de vie dans la commune
donc voilà il faut qu'on essaye même si
sur le plan à certains nombre de mesures
doivent être
légit d'ordre législatif je pense à la
clarification de la nomenclature qui est
définie dans le décret pour permettre
aux élus de continuer à développer des
espaces naturels et de loisirs sans
utiliser l'endroit à construire par
exemple ça je pense que c'est c'est
important et puis il faudrait aussi que
les projets de renaturation qui serait
fait d'ici
2030 soit pris en compte voilà
donc tout ça on a compris que c'était
des difficultés importantes mais
on y travaille avec Christophe
bien merci beaucoup madame la ministre
vous avez peut-être un point encore non
pardon
parce que quand j'ai dit la loi c'est
vrai que intégrer les projets d'intérêt
national et régional il faudra
un point législatif un projet législatif
bien merci de nous avoir consacré
au-delà du temps à partir avec vos
équipes mais vous savez que c'est un peu
toujours à la délégation au cas une
vocation transversale
il y a toujours beaucoup de questions et
donc on manquera sans doute pas de se
rencontrer à nouveau merci
peut-être à l'intention de mes collègues
parce que je vois que tout le monde
s'échappe prochaine réunion donc le 19
audition de Monsieur Christophe Béchu et
on l'évoquait tout à l'heure le 17 nous
aurons donc Monsieur Olivier Klein donc
pour continuer nos travaux merci à tous